[Applause]
first off I want to send all my love to
the family - pops gee mom
Lauren Imani cross black Sam Adams Jorge
pH copy J stone Jay Jay rot and I'm
saying a whole family already know what
it is with me nip you see me that's you
think that's my brother from the other
color you know what I'm saying oh he was
like a real big brother to me like we
like we like every time I'm with nipsey
we're not talking about no nothing that
don't mean nothing we always talking
about goes family homies plays we trying
to make like like I was having
conversations with nip about I'm like
look bro we got we got some lights can
pretty girls we got a raise we in
trouble my when we going to you and I'm
saying and uh bro always gave me advice
you send me this loadout [ __ ] he gave me
books to read like that I'm like this is
different man you're I mean I could talk
about a lot but bro fall for me I fall
for him
you feel me that's I look at a boat like
a real big brother he sent me a text
messages on my birthday March 9 he text
me like happy birthday bro I want to
congratulate you for building a brand
that's gonna last forever respect and I
replied like good-looking bro
I told boss said hustle the motivation
money you know what I'm saying so so so
I just want to let bro know I want to
congratulate beau for his legacy and
everything he did all the game he gave
me all the people he touched and for the
brand he left behind on the behalf of
the west coast on
half of La the streets my he loved you
my I'm gonna miss you my hey you already
know what it is
all money info honey no mines and like
Lauren said the mother marathon
continues
[Applause]
you